When time travel gets involved there isn't
much that isn't possible, and with so many
possibilities on the table it's easy to choke
the air with questions.
In the aftermath of Terminator: Dark Fate,
this franchise has as many dangling plot threads
as ever.
Sadly, we learn early in Terminator: Dark
Fate that John Connor is no longer in the
land of the living.
Even though the only bad guy Terminator we
meet in Terminator 2 is Robert Patrick's T-1000,
in Dark Fate we learn SkyNet covered all of
its angles and sent more Terminators back
in time that we didn't know about.
After the events of Terminator 2, one of those
Terminators, the same model as the classic
Schwarzenegger cyborg we're used to, kills
John Connor in front of Sarah.
With SkyNet no longer in existence, the Terminator
receives no new orders and decides to learn
to become more human, eventually regretting
his actions.
It begs the question of why SkyNet sends this
older Terminator model as a safety net when
the T-1000 version we see in Terminator 2
is clearly superior and can take a lot more
punishment.
The real answer is obvious, because Arnold
didn't play the T-1000, and the filmmakers
wanted Arnold back.
But narratively we don't get any kind of explanation.
Maybe T-1000s were rare?
Perhaps one T-1000 per time travel kill mission
was the limit in SkyNet Central?
We'll probably never know.
When Sarah Connor explains that the T-1000
wasn't the only Terminator SkyNet sent back
during the events of Terminator 2, she doesn't
specify that the one who kills John is the
only other Terminator.
Since Carl is still around in a world without
Skynet, it's possible that there are other
Skynet models that were sent back in time.
Could there be more Schwarzenegger cyborgs
out there, growing old in cabins in the woods
and working modest jobs?
Maybe a Terminator who sells vacuum cleaners,
or an Uber driver?
"Give you a lift?"
It leaves possibilities open for future Terminator
installments, particularly if they want to
bring Schwarzenegger back.
Sure, his death looks pretty final at the
end of Dark Fate...exactly like it does at
the end of Terminator...and the end of Terminator
2.
Once Grace accepts Sarah Connor into the fold,
Connor explains that for years she's been
receiving texts with coordinates from an anonymous
source.
Once she goes to the coordinates to investigate,
she finds a Terminator waiting for her.
We don't know exactly how many times Sarah's
done this, though it seems she's killed at
least two or three Terminators offscreen.
The question is, why were those Terminators
sent back?
What were their missions?
"Who sent him back?"
"Those files have been erased."
"Oh that's convenient."
Since SkyNet is gone, they must have been
Legion-controlled Terminators, so were they
all supposed to kill Dani before Sarah killed
them?
If so, that would seem strange.
We're given the impression Dani has spent
most, if not all, of her life in Mexico up
to this point, meaning any Terminators sent
to kill her would show up there.
And if all of the Terminators Sarah hunted
down popped up in Mexico, you'd also think
she might wonder why and maybe investigate
exactly who the cyborgs were looking for.
Since Sarah doesn't seem to have any idea
who Dani is before she saves her from the
Rev-9 Terminator, it's likely Dani hasn't
been Legion's only target over the years.
Let's talk about Carl's family.
Do they really not know he's a cyborg?
Carl explains to Sarah that his relationship
with his wife isn't physical.
Still, the boy he's helped raise since infancy
is a teenager, meaning Carl's been with his
wife for over a decade.
You don't live with someone for that long
and fail to notice their physical "quirks."
It's not impossible, but it's a tough sell.
There are a couple of other things.
First, when Carl tells his wife and child
to leave home and that he won't be back, they
don't make a lot of fuss.
You would think a family might have a few
discussions before agreeing to completely
split forever.
Second, the family has a dog.
Anyone who's seen 1984's Terminator knows
that dogs don't like Terminators.
It's why human communities in the future keep
dogs at their entrances, and why at the end
of the film Sarah Connor has a new dog in
her jeep.
How is this dog hanging out with Carl without
constantly freaking out?
At first Sarah Connor assumes that, like in
her case in 1984's Terminator, Dani's unborn
child is the key to defeating Legion.
Once we find out it's Dani herself that Grace
is desperate to protect, you might wonder
how much the Dani of the future has seen of
the events of Terminator: Dark Fate.
Are Grace, Sarah, Dani, and Carl succeeding
in creating a new future, or has the Dani
of the future seen all of it before?
When we meet the older, more battle-hardened
Dani, does she know the young girl she saves
from scavengers is destined to sacrifice herself
for her?
She seems to be a little affected by learning
Grace's name, so that could be the case.
But there are some reasons to believe the
heroes are genuinely changing things.
The future Dani tells Grace not to tell her
younger self that she'll grow to become humanity's
unifying figure, yet Grace does reveal it.
So why would Dani bother giving her that advice
if she already knows Grace is going to ignore
it?
One of the most inexplicable things that happens
in Terminator: Dark Fate is that the heroes
get a very unlikely ally, the U.S. military.
Deciding they'll need an EMP weapon to fry
the Rev-9 Terminator's systems, Sarah gets
in touch with Major Dean, who says he's committing
treason by stealing the item for Sarah.
The Rev-9 attacks during the handoff and the
heroes escape to a nearby military airfield.
All on Major Dean's say-so, the heroes meet
no military resistance and are allowed to
abruptly commandeer a C-5 Galaxy transport
aircraft and receive a fighter escort in the
air.
Just who is Major Dean that he can get them
all of this?
From Terminator 2 we know that, offscreen,
Sarah had brief relationships with lots of
military "types," but the impression given
is that none of them were high-ranking military
officers.
The idea that this rag-tag crew of cyborgs
and wanted criminals could peacefully commandeer
a military aircraft suggests one of two things:
some lazy storytelling, or in the world of
Terminator the U.S. government knows more
about these time-jumping cyborgs than they're
letting on.
Maybe certain officers like Major Dean are
tasked with giving people like Sarah Connor
off-the-books support if the opportunity arises.
In Dark Fate we learn that while Sarah Connor
and the other heroes of Terminator 2 succeeded
in ridding the future of SkyNet, another artificial
intelligence, this time a cyberwarfare AI
called Legion, is what spells doom for civilization.
There is one question left unanswered, though
to be fair, the same question is left unanswered
in the other Terminator films.
Specifically: Why?
Why is it that as soon as these powerful new
forms of artificial intelligence go online,
their first thought is to eradicate or subjugate
humanity?
Do these AIs simply see us as inferior beings
who are wrecking a planet they could be better
caretakers for?
Do they see us as a threat and figure that
killing us all is the best safeguard?
Any of the answers could work, but we've yet
to hear them.
All we know is that apparently when computers
become self-aware, they immediately want to
kill everybody.
Maybe it's all the memes we made them endure?
"Computer, load up celery man please."
"Yes, Paul."
Who knows!
Terminator: Dark Fate ends with three dead
cyborgs, The Rev-9, the T-800, and Grace.
What should not escape the notice of any Terminator
fan is while the Rev-9 body seems pretty well
slagged, Grace's body and the T-800 are more
or less intact and we never get any indication
that the bodies are destroyed.
It could be that Sarah and Dani destroyed
the corpses offscreen, but if not, there's
a chance Sarah forgot a very important lesson
from the first two Terminator movies.
In Terminator 2: Judgment Day, we learn it
was largely because of the body of the T-800
Sarah Connor kills in Terminator that SkyNet
was being developed.
At the end of that film, the T-800 who protects
John Connor chooses to descend into molten
liquid, destroying his body.
Unless there's a body disposal scene we don't
see, Terminator: Dark Fate ends with the bodies
of several cyborgs for someone to pick apart,
reverse engineer, and create Legion or an
AI just as bad.
In fact, even if the bodies were destroyed
off-screen, there are still the scans of Grace's
body taken while she was in Border Patrol
custody.
This is a question that someone should have
asked a long time ago.
In Terminator, the super-intelligent AI SkyNet
sends a single T-800 Terminator back in time
to kill the mother of John Connor.
It almost succeeds.
In Terminator 2: Judgment Day, the same AI
sends a new and improved liquid metal cyborg,
the T-1000, back in time to kill John Connor.
In spite of a T-800 sent by the humans to
protect John and the fact that Sarah Connor
is trained, heavily armed, and expecting an
attack from the future, the T-1000 almost
succeeds.
And now, in Terminator: Dark Fate, the new
super-intelligent AI Legion sends a single
Rev-9 Terminator back in time to kill Dani
Ramos.
Dani has backup from a cybernetically augmented
human soldier, another T-800 Terminator, and
an even more heavily armed Sarah Connor, and
still the Rev-9 almost succeeds.
Do you think...you know...one of those obscenely
intelligent AI world-killers might just splurge
and send back, maybe...two Terminators?
Sure, we find out SkyNet did just that, but
the Terminators SkyNet sent back weren't working
together.
If one Terminator, completely on its own,
almost does the job, why not send back partners?
What's the big deal?
Maybe even a three-fer?
Four?
Make a party of it.
"Well isn't this cute...a Terminator convention."
Everything about the journey of Carl feels
like the end of Arnold Schwarzenegger's involvement
with the Terminator franchise.
Just as the earlier model does at the end
of Terminator 3, Carl sacrifices himself to
make sure the Rev-9 is down for the count.
When he talks about telling his family that
he "won't be back," if feels like he's telling
us the same thing.
Also, Schwarzenegger's in his 70s, and his
best killer android days are arguably behind
him.
But you never know.
Terminator: Dark Fate leaves the door open
for Schwarzenegger's return.
In Dark Fate we learn that during the events
of Terminator 2, SkyNet sent at least one
other Terminator to 1991; there's no reason
it couldn't have sent others.
Not to mention that from the texts Carl sends
Sarah over the years to warn her of Terminator
infiltration, Legion was sending more cyborgs
to the present day.
There's no way to know for sure if Sarah got
them all.
Schwarzenegger's not getting any younger,
but he can probably keep fighting cyborgs
for a couple more years if he wants.
Dude's still in great shape.
"Come with me if you want to lift."
There's probably a good chance that this really
is the end for Linda Hamilton's involvement
in the Terminator franchise.
Hamilton apparently didn't even initially
want to come back for Terminator: Dark Fate.
In an interview about the movie, Hamilton
seemed less than eager to return to the franchise,
quipping,
"I've been threatening to fake my own death
so I wouldn't have to do the next one if there
is one."
Ironically, while it does seem more likely
we'll see Schwarzenegger than it does we'll
see Hamilton, it's Sarah Connor's story that's
left with more potential.
By the end of Dark Fate Connor seems to have
found whatever peace she's likely to find
over the death of her son, so in that sense
you could argue her story is over.
But Dani Ramos still has a big fight to prepare
for, and Sarah Connor is her only surviving
ally.
As a bonafide badass Terminator hunter who's
been killing time-hopping cyborgs for decades,
Sarah Connor is the best mentor the future
savior of humanity could ask for.
"Enough of a resume for you?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.